Everyone loves the Marvel Cinematic Universe.
Everyone loves Keanu Reeves.
How long before the two shall meet?
In a chat with ComicBook.com's Brandon Davis,
Marvel Studios head honcho Kevin Feige revealed
that the studio has had Reeves in mind for
a long, long time - and that they're just
waiting for the right role for the beloved
actor to present itself.
Feige's remarks came in response to a line
of questioning which he's got to be used to
by now, as Davis wanted to know which of his
favorite actors might be up for an invitation
to the MCU.
The first name on his list?
None other than Keanu Reeves, who at the moment
is having something of a career resurgence.
"No way!"
Yes way!
With a chuckle, Feige admitted:
Feige went on to compare the situation to
Marvel's pursuit of another high-profile actor
who recently joined the party: Jake Gyllenhaal,
whom he said the studio had conversations
with, quote, "multiple times" before finally
casting him as Quentin Beck - AKA Mysterio
- in the upcoming Spider-Man: Far From Home.
"This is Mr. Beck."
"We could use someone like you on my world."
"Your world?"
Feige expressed his hope that the same patient
approach would eventually pay off with Reeves;
he conspicuously did not mention the fact
that multiple outlets have reported the star
to be in talks for The Eternals, which is
looking to be the first major release on the
"Cosmic" side of Marvel's Phase 4.
Feige's remarks are lent credence by the fact
that, way back in 2014, Reeves was rumored
to be up for the title role in Doctor Strange,
a role which eventually fell into the very
capable hands of British actor Benedict Cumberbatch.
At the time, Reeves responded to the rumors
with a mix of excitement and trepidation.
While he admitted to watching and enjoying
superhero flicks, claiming that he, quote,
"...grew up on them and comics and graphic
novels," he admitted to being leery of signing
the kind of multiple-picture deal which Marvel
famously requires of its more high-profile
stars.
He told Collider:
At this point, Reeves doesn't have to do anything
just for the sake of doing it; the star is
having the kind of moment that would make
peers green with envy if he weren't such a
legitimately breathtaking guy.
"You're breathtaking!"
"YOU'RE breathtaking!"
After rocketing to the A-list thanks to his
role as Neo in the Matrix series, Reeves spent
the next decade or so appearing in decidedly
smaller projects before stumbling upon his
next paradigm-shifting franchise.
That would be John Wick, the insanely innovative
and box office-decimating shoot 'em up series
which firmly cemented his status as an action
movie legend.
Reeves also made a splash this year in the
rapturously received Netflix rom-com Always
Be My Maybe, and as Duke Caboom in Toy Story
4, which has blown critics out of their seats.
On top of all this, he'll soon be returning
to one of his most fondly-remembered roles:
that of Ted "Theodore" Logan, the time-traveling
rocker with a heart of gold, in next year's
long-awaited three-quel Bill & Ted Face the
Music.
Oh, and he's set to appear in CD Projekt Red's
2020 video game, Cyberpunk 2077, playing - wait
for it - a dude named Johnny Silverhand.
"Wake the f--- up, samurai.
We have a city to burn."
The guy can seemingly do it all - so, with
the Marvel Cinematic Universe dominating pop
culture like nothing else in recent memory,
the time seems oh-so-right for Feige and company
to find that perfect role that they've long
been seeking for the star.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
stuff are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.